Speaker 1: So we're continuing to follow sort
of two stories that are coming together. One
is this brewing civil war within the Republican
Party told you last week, just as one data point
thirteen Republicans voted in favor of Joe Biden's
$1.2 trillion, the eventual $1.2 trillion stimulus
package. Thirteen Republicans crossing party lines
to vote in favor Trump Republicans immediately
demanding the removal of those 13 Republicans,
just one data point in this growing civil war,
and we've looked at others. That's one story which
we're going to talk about today. The second is
what's going to happen in 2024 in terms of Trump
running versus not running in the relationship
with Mike Pence, etc.? Well, we have one story
that brings both of these two elements together.
One of the former White House communications
directors under Donald Trump, Alyssa Farah,
was on CNN over the weekend and said No one Mike
Pence is now ashamed of Donald Trump. And number
two, she believes that Pence or someone else like
Ron DeSantis or others, are going to run against
Trump in 2024. In the Republican primary, if Trump
runs and will try to go after Trump's voters. Now,
there's so much to talk about here. So many
different aspects to this that are important.
But let's first look at what exactly Alyssa Farah
said when she appeared on CNN. And we know from
the Trump side his contempt for Mike Pence is
very clear, telling him, Don't be p the p word.
I don't know if I can say it or not. With regard
to his behavior on January 6th and not stopping
the certification of the vote, which of course,
Mike Pence had no authority to do defending,
as I told you earlier, the calls to quote Hang
Mike Pence on January six from his own supporters.
We know Trump's ire towards Pence. Here is the
first indication, direct indication that we have
from someone who would know that Pence is
ashamed of Trump as well. Let's listen there.
Speaker 5: So why did Pence talk to him after
this? I mean, that was something as just an
observer. Here you have protesters chanting,
Hang Mike Pence and all this going on. And yet
they still talked after the insurrection.
Why is that? What do you make of that?
So to the best of my knowledge, I think Pence,
by default, is somebody who's very deferential
to both the chain of command in the institution
of the presidency. And I think he would always
take a call from Donald Trump. He would always
take a meeting if one was requested from him.
I think that must have been those must have been
very awkward and tough conversations. Also, I've
always known Mike Pence to be a person of deep
character and conviction, so I don't doubt that
in those private communications, he communicated
how bad that was and how inappropriate was,
but not for him, but for the country. But yeah, I
can't imagine that was a comfortable conversation,
and I think that you're going to see a bit more
distancing as time goes on. Look, there's aspects
of the record they did together that I know
Pence is proud of. But I know he is ashamed of
that day. He's ashamed of how the former president
conducted himself. Wow. So we expect that Donald
Trump will run again for twenty twenty four.
Do you think that Pence will run against him?
So I think you will. And I'm saying this with
no knowledge outside of any special knowledge
that's informed speculation, let's be honest.
I do think that there's this belief that people
are just going to clear the field for Trump. I
actually think some folks are teeing up to run.
I think Pence could be one of them. I think two
Santas might be one of them. I think Mike Pompeo
is looking at a at a political team and what
that could look like. And it's a good thing
for the party. A coronation of Donald Trump would
be the worst thing, both for the party, but more
importantly, for the country. Interesting. We're
going to need to have these debates on the stage,
by the way of was the election stolen? And
that's going to be a tough question for some
of these folks to answer, because somehow that
Speaker 1: would be a fascinating debate to
see Republicans have in the primary in 2024
Speaker 5: really toed the line of the Big
Lie. So I'd love to see some folks run who are
going to acknowledge the truth and the reality
and actually just try to win over more voters.
So you think so you do think from your, you know,
from your perch, which is a good perch because
you used to be press secretary for Pence?
You think he will from your your view, what makes
you think that? And what do you think that would
be like? Because all we have seen from Pence and
Trump is Pence being deferential to Trump and
being a loyalist to Trump? What do you expect? I
think that Pence knows he's uniquely positioned in
that he can tout the record in the things that so
Speaker 1: so this is where
she goes off the rails.
Speaker 5: Our kids are still
still wish you were in office. The seventy
four million people who voted for Trump,
but without a lot of the downside.
Speaker 1: OK, so let's let's let's discuss
this. First of all, this is great from the
standpoint of hurting Republicans by having them
hurt themselves, by fighting among themselves.
I've said before, it's really terrible. It's sad.
It's embarrassing. It's humiliating that Democrats
have so little going for them that essentially
they have to hope that the right just damages
itself. And that's a. Disastrous place to be in,
it means you have very little going for
yourself, it's an extremely low standard,
but to the extent that we want the right to fight
among itself, what Alyssa Farah is pointing out
here is fantastic. Pence ashamed of Trump? Trump
has furious Pence. Whatever the case may be,
they may run against each other. They may be going
after the same voters. That's great. But one thing
you have to realize from a practical standpoint
is anybody supporting Donald Trump today
is not voting for Mike Pence in 2024. Unless
something radical happens. And what I mean by that
is that the people still supporting Donald Trump
and by supporting him, I don't just mean I voted
for him, and I probably would again. I mean, the
people still supporting Trump's message today of
the election was stolen and it was all rigged.
And Pence was bad, and he did an unpatriotic
thing and all these different things. You were
so aggressively committed to the whole cult,
if that's your belief that you're not voting for
Mike Pence in 2024 in a Republican primary. So the
idea that there's so much to fight over in terms
of swaying voters in 24, I think a this affair
is wrong on that, but I'd love to see them try
because it will damage themselves. But here's the
second part of it. Alyssa Farah talks about Pence
can go and run on the record of Trump. Pence on
the accomplishments. What is she talking about?
What? See, this is where I continue to say just
because we come across a Republican that says like
one or two reasonable things like Joe Biden really
won. Liz Cheney is an example. These are still
outrageous Republicans who believe crazy things
like Pence has a record to run on. It's completely
delusional. First of all, to think that Mike Pence
has a political future of any serious kind in
the United States, he served as a sort of shield,
arguably to the most incompetent president
in history. Donald Trump to, I guess,
help him win some religious voters. And I think
he probably did do that, particularly in 2016. And
now those very aggressive Trump voters hate Pence
because Pence didn't help Trump steal the 2020
election. Who is Pence's constituency, really?
Because if you if you believe it was stolen,
then you believe Pence did something wrong by not
taking it for Donald Trump. And if you don't like
Trump, you've bailed on Trump long ago, and you
probably realize that there are no accomplishments
to speak of. So it's kind of like a Jeff Sessions
type situation. So very interesting to hear from
Alyssa Farah. I think she's way off on the idea of
Mike Pence having an independent political future